David Boder: [In English] We are still continuing...We are still continuing the charming evening at the home of Admiral Kahn, and we are now inteviewing his present chauffeur who, I am told, was active in the Resistance. Madame Kahn will help us as a translator. Madame Kahn, will you ask him to give us first his name and how old he is?
Charles Jean: [In French] Alors Charles Jean [exact spelling unknown], 31 ans.
David Boder: [In English] Now, Charles, will you ask him to tell us what he remembers from the time the war started where he was? And then what was he doing, gradually, until liberation.
Charles Jean: [In French] Je suis parti le 26 août 1939, j’étais mobilisé à Dunkerque dans le Maine, et j’étais prisonnier le 4 juin 1940. Je me suis évadé de Dunkerque le 25 juin 1940, et je suis rentré chez moi à Vichy. Par la suite, j’étais...je travaillais, et ensuite j’étais repris par les Allemands au mois d’avril ’43, pour aller travailler en Allemagne. Et je me suis évadé une fois de plus de Cravant dans l’Yonne. Et à ce moment-là, je suis rentré au Maquis, le Maquis d’Auvergne, aux Brugerons à côté d’Olliergues.
David Boder: [In English] Would you ask him...[unintelligible aside to interpreter] Will you ask him to tell us, what does the word “Maquis” mean?
Charles Jean: [In French] Alors, un Maquis, le Maquis où j’étais...nous faisions partie des Francs-tireurs et partisans français, nous étions en général de jeunes hommes commandés par un Commandant, tout un état-major. Nous étions commandés exactement comme dans l’armée. Nous avions des armes qui nous étaient parachutées par les Anglais, et celles que nous pouvions récupérer sur les Allemands que nous prenions prisonniers. Nous étions commandés par un groupement qui se trouvait à Clermont-Ferrand, et dont nous défendions, au Maquis où j’étais, et nous étions très bien d’ailleurs commandés par des chefs compétents qui avaient déjà fait la guerre et qui prenaient leur travail très au sérieux. Nous étions, nous étions environ, dans ce Maquis dont je faisais partie, environ trois cents et moi je me trouvais au poste de commandement. J’avais l’avantage d’être chauffeur du commandant, ce qui me donnait beaucoup d’avantages par rapport à mes camarades qui, des trois quarts du temps, couchaient dans des bois et n’avaient pas le même confort. Je vais vous parler de la phase finale de notre Maquis, c’est-à-dire la prise de Thiers, la capitale de la coutellerie. Nous avons été attaqués au poste de commandement le 23 août 1944 par un détachement allemand d’SS que nous l’avons su plus tard avait l’ordre de nous exterminer coûte que coûte. Nous avons résisté assez bien d’ailleurs, puisque les Allemands n’ont pas pu nous prendre. Et le Commandant par représailles a décidé à ce jour-là d’attaquer Thiers. Nous sommes partis à 150 environ. Moi, je ne suis venu que par la suite et mes camarades sont partis d’abord, à 150 le 24 août ou le 23, je ne me rappelle pas exactement, pour attaquer Thiers. Ils étaient environ 150 hommes pour prendre les deux ou trois cents Allemands qui se trouvaient là-bas. Nous avons attaqué Thiers par le nord et l’est. La bataille était très dure. Elle a duré d’ailleurs une journée et demie, et nous avons eu onze morts chez nous et une quarantaine chez les Allemands. Et en fin de compte, leurs chefs se sont rendus sans conditions...nous en a fait prisonniers, ainsi que quelques miliciens qui se trouvaient avec eux. Par la suite nous avons pu récupérer dans les Allemands qui se trouvaient là cinq d’entre eux qui avaient massacré des camarades de chez nous et nous les avons fusillés, ainsi que les sept miliciens qui se trouvaient là.
David Boder: [In English] [interrupts] All right, now...continuez.
Charles Jean: [In French] Après, c’est à ce moment que la garde du Maréchal sont venus nous rejoindre pour libérer le reste du secteur qui se trouvait encore quelques Allemands. Ensuite, la guerre était finie pour nous. Nous avons été casernés à Clermont-Ferrand, la caserne Desaix et l’armée a jugé que notre rôle était fini. Je suis retourné dans mon foyer.
David Boder: [In English] Was he taken prisoner by the Germans? [off mic with interpreter] No, afterwards, when he was in the Maquis. Was he never taken prisoner? [off mic with interpreter] He was taken for compulsory...[more than one person speaking at once] He went to the Maquis. Can he tell us about some details of the [unintelligible]. You think that’s all covered. Uh huh. And where did we find him? Where was he when...? Who came in? The English or the Americans?
Marcelle Kahn: [In French] Quelles étaient les premières troupes alliées que vous avez vues?
Charles Jean: Les premières troupes alliées, ce sont des Américains et...les Américains et les Français. A Thiers.
David Boder: [In English] So how did the French troops from there leave, right there after the.... . . Now how did it come out? There were French troops. That I know, where were they during that time? [aside to interpreter] Whose organization in France...Who was in the Maquis? [several voices talking at once] And the forces which came after...The troops who were landing in south France some weeks before...[more than one person talking] Our troops and especially in this town, the first Allied troops, regular troops were from Africa...[several voices talking at once]
David Boder: [In English] And they were combined with the troops from Africa.
David Boder: So when the regular troops came in, did the Maquis continue to do partisan work? [unintelligible discussion off mic]
David Boder: Well, what are you doing now?
Charles Jean: [In French] Maintenant, je suis chauffeur d’Ingénieur Général Kahn et je suis très content, je suis très bien.
David Boder: [In English] [to interpreter] Well, that’s good. And uh, how old is he?
Charles Jean: [In French] Trente-et-un ans.
David Boder: [In English] Are you married?
Charles Jean: [In French] Oui.
David Boder: [In English] [to interpreter] Was he married before the war?
Charles Jean: [In French] Ah, non, non, pas avant la guerre, je me suis marié que maintenant.
David Boder: [In English] He was alone.... Were there many married Maquis?
Charles Jean: [In French] Ah oui, beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup d’hommes mariés.
David Boder: [In English] Well, didn’t their families get into trouble because of the Maquis?
Charles Jean: [In French] Ah, oui, oui, à Clermont-Ferrand, pas mal de nos camarades trouvaient leurs femmes et leurs enfants ennuyés par la Gestapo parce qu’eux-mêmes s’étaient rendus aux Maquis. Et nous avons organisé d’ailleurs pour les femmes de ces camarades dans un pays à côté de chez nous, nous avons organisé dans un hôtel un centre d’accueil autrement dit pour les recevoir pour qu’elles ne soient pas inquiétées et elles étaient sous notre protection. Mais les femmes ne jouaient aucun rôle effectif avec nous. Il n’y avait pas de femmes dans notre groupement, mais simplement des femmes de ces camarades qui étaient à l’abri, près de nous.
David Boder: [In English] Well, and how did the general population treat the Maquis?
Charles Jean: [In French] Eh bien, en Auvergne, la population était très gentille avec nous. Nous avions en principe tout ce qu’il nous fallait. Nous allions dans les fermes nous ravitailler. Nous n’avions pas d’argent, nous payions...nous donnions des bons. Des bons de réquisition qui par la suite ont été payées. Et nous faisions de même pour le tabac, ainsi que pour les automobiles. Dans les automobiles, nous prenions autant que possible des automobiles des collaborateurs. Moi même j’ai pris celle du Général Ferré [?] qui commandait les gardes mobiles à Vichy, puisque c’était un collaborateur notoire. Je lui ai volé sa voiture, autrement dit “piquer” en termes de Maquisard, lui piquer sa voiture à Vichy et je l’ai ramenée au Maquis, où elle nous a rendu de grands services.
David Boder: [In English] Yes, now, here is another question. Where did the Maquis get their supplies?
Unknown person: [unknown person off mic] He told you. In the town.
David Boder: Yes, but where did they get their military supplies? [unintelligible conversation off mic] Yes, did they have radio service?
Charles Jean: [In French] Ah, oui, nous avions un service radio. Nous avions le code. D’ailleurs, je ne le connaissais pas, moi. C’était l’Officier qui savait ça. Nous communiquions avec Londres pour les parachutages et le gros de nos armes nous parvenait surtout de ce que nous pouvions récupérer sur les Allemands. Parce que le mouvement de l’AS [armée secrète?] c’était beaucoup mieux ravitaillé en armes que nous mêmes parce que qu’ils étaient respectés et les Mouvements Unis de la Résistance c’était beaucoup mieux approvisionné en armes que nous. Nous nous débrouillions par nos propres moyens pour ainsi dire.
David Boder: [In English] All right, I thank you very much for this...[unintelligible]
David Boder: [In French] Merci beaucoup.